every conveys your famously a very lazy
actor you would not only in a play like
this I wouldn't do a play I can walk out
on stage to thousands of people and just
say what I want but if it's lines if
it's Epson or Shakespeare I know they
probably know the play too so I could go
wrong do that I mean I wouldn't want to
let them that I don't want to have to I
don't on that moment of getting
something wrong I can't get it wrong
when it's me because I'm making it all
and so that would be that I know I could
I couldn't do it I really once I was in
a production of a Shakespeare play with
Coriolanus and and there was one night
where somebody actually had bought the
play along and a little nightlight so
they could read it weird no no no III
it's it's it's um that's not part of it
they had a nightlight yeah the Donmar
that the smallest theatre and they've
got a nightlight i banned ice in drinks
at my gigs cuz it puts me off I'm like a
right little fascist I can't stand
anyone talking or no ice in that you
know because it rattles is annoying me
I'm talking but I know it's quiet it's
dark I can't see them it's no yeah I
can't I couldn't do a play people try
anything in school or any have you ever
done acting yeah I did oh I did the Pied
Piper in a primary school I was the man
if another body in the Pied Piper the
mayor is the party air that mayor is
kind of the person all the rats coming
yeah oh yes very challenging we're all
in
[Music]
you